je tiens à vous remercier tous d'être venus et je
pensais que nous commencerions par apprendre
à nous connaître très bien je vais
commencer mon nom est bob avec un b d'
accord bienvenue bob j'aime la ville j'aime
ma femme je  j'adore ma fille et j'adore
avoir la chance de passer du temps avec les gars,
donc je suis vraiment dans ce que vous faites
ici une fois par semaine loin de la femme et des
enfants qui racontent des blagues cochonnes en buvant
des bières si nous sommes bons super merci
bob yep qu'est-ce que tu fais à propos
de jamarcus de mon nom euh récemment très
heureusement divorcé et cherche juste à
s'impliquer davantage dans la communauté locale
bien c'était simple
bienvenue à marcus
euh aussi euh j'ai ce scénario dans
mon esprit jeune femme au foyer asiatique sexy seule
la nuit  effrayé un bruit par les
poubelles
mieux appelé la montre du quartier je
me présente avoir l'air héroïque et puis je reçois ça
elle craint d'accord
écoutez-moi maintenant
je suis aussi intéressé par ce qui m'arrive